a lot of those aspects in the games oh
and here he is smiling
maybe magnus was listening into those
stats he's thinking this is a chance to
prove them wrong
but yeah that must be maybe a connection
mathematics that was mvl's background in
the heat
maybe he's very aware of these stats
maybe he works on the specific areas of
the game and okay meanwhile the game has
kicked off
queensborough opening will we see the
grinsfeld defense that tends to be
vascular
go-to opening he's very predictable in
the opening stage and we did see 99
accuracy in the openings for him
occasionally though he does walk into
some home brew
kind of opening preparation from the
opponent because he is so predictable
and that tends to be um the situation
when these two face off and it is
already getting crazy white pushed harry
the h-bomb forward in an early stage
that's trendy but not normally
recommended and a trade of pawns in the
center is imminent will black recapture
that pawn now with his knight magnus
still very happy uh laughing away there
no okay i've never seen this before this
is just crazy stuff white's pushed a
pawn on one side then he's put his
knight on the other side of the board
this is going against all conventional
wisdom i say don't try it at home quite
regularly when these guys play but this
one definitely don't try it at home